مركبات مشاه قتاليه وانظمه مضاده للثواريخ
هو متعهدت بتسليمها الى اوكرانيا كل من
الولايات المتحده والمانيا دعم عسكري يمثل
مرحله جديده من المساعدات الغربيه
لسد الغزو الروسي
سنزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا سنوفر مركبات
مشاهد
اوكرانيا ايضا في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الهجمات الجويه الروسيه
لدعم اوكرانيا
ارسل الدبابات القتاليه خفيفه الى كياذ
اعلان رحبت به الحكومه الاوكرانيه
اقدموا فرنسا مستوى جديد من الدعم الدفعي
الاوروبي الاوكرانيا واشكروا رئيس ماكرو
على هذه القياده سيكون لدينا المزيد من
المركبات المدرعه هذا ما يعطي اشاره واضحه
لجميع شراء كائن الاخرين لا يوجد سبب
منطقي لعدم تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات من
النوع الغربي حلفاء اوكرانيا
بدبابات سوفياتيه السنه لكن ليس بمركبات
غربيه تصميم بالرغم من طلباتك يافا
المتكرره لكن اوروبا متردده وتخشى من
التورط الفعلي في الصراع الروسي الاوكراني